cynthia peine combien avez vous écrit
deux livres ont combien de livres ont
été écrits à votre sujet le troisième
c'est explicite il a été écrit par gabe
rock c'était juste sur le procès les
témoins english madame était écrit par
paul bailet ça c'était le vrai c'est ma
biographie c'est la vraie histoire pas
de mensonge la vérité en fait trop de
vérité j'aurais pas dû en dire autant
et le troisième c'est un livre drôle
vous savez pour faire marrer les gens si
à peine 1 téning comme c'est vraiment le
cadeau idéal pour noël qu'est ce qui est
le nom plein de trucs marrants
comment organiser une partie par tous
oui une partouze il ya aussi un chapitre
spécial pour conseiller les policiers
sur la meilleure façon de s'infiltrer
dans les partys ce qu'il doit faire ce
qu'ils ne doivent pas faire c'est
vraiment très très drôle
il ya aussi le problème des domestiques
parce que j'ai toujours eu l'habitude
d'avoir beaucoup d'esclaves à la maison
quand on veut organiser des partouzes
régulièrement on doit absolument avoir
des esclaves à la maison ils sont très
très utiles parce que notre époque vous
savez qu'on ne trouve plus de domestique
c'est vraiment un livre très très drôle
les policiers peuvent aussi apprendre
comment rentrer incognito dans une
partouze vous aviez pas mal d'esclaves
ici ils faisaient tous les ménages
après les partouzes parce qu'il y avait
un bordel terrible après ici avec
beaucoup de boulot les esclaves étaient
très utiles pour nettoyer comment en
êtes vous arrivé à la prostitution
c'est une longue histoire
j'étais serveuse
dans un restaurant à victoria station je
travaillais pour des italiens est les
prostituées venaient souvent manger là
où je travaillais j'ai toujours été
fasciné par les prostituées elles m'ont
toujours intrigué j'avais un fils
j'étais pas marié et j'avais du mal à
joindre les deux bouts
un jour une prostituée est venu me voir
et il m'a dit je vous donnerai trois
livres par new c'était en 59 et ça
faisait pas mal d'argent parce que moi
je gagnais trois livres par semaine à
l'époque elle m'a dit je vous donnerai
trois livres par jour
si vous me prêtez votre chambre j'ai dit
ben non il faut que je dorme quelques
pas parce que moi je pensais que les
prostituées travaillaient seulement la
nuit mais elle m'a dit non non je ferai
seulement montré trois clients et je
serais parti avant que vous reveniez du
restaurant pour dormir alors c'est comme
ça que ça a commencé
en plus j'ai toujours été une bonne
femme d'affaires parce que je venais
d'un milieu commerçants mon père tenait
un salon de coiffure
alors je me suis dit si j'arrive à louer
un petit studio à londres pour 10 livres
par semaine ce qui faisait déjà beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque et si je sous loue
ce studio à une prostituée pour disons
25 livres par semaine je pourrais me
faire de l'art journée et c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé parce que les
prostituées n'arrive jamais à louer des
studios je sais pas pourquoi peut-être
parce qu'on voit bien que ce sont des
prostituées mais moi j'allais dans les
agences immobilières avec des chaussures
à talons plats et presque pas de
maquillage et jeux prétendaient que
j'étais veuve et j'avais de l'argent je
trouve facilement des studio à louer
parce que j'avais un compte en banque et
parce que je travaillais alors
j'arrivais à louer un studio et après
j'allais à park lane parce qu'à l'époque
toutes les prostituées faisait le
trottoir du côté de parc lann je
repérais les filles plus jolie qui
faisait le trottoir
j'allais les voir et je leur disais
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'un studio
et ses filles avaient toujours besoin
d'un studio
je pensais que c'était les freins les
plus jolies paires est le mieux le loyer
est en fait je me trompais il y en avait
qui me il y en avait qui il payait ne
s'était pas les plus belles filles qui
ne paient le plus régulièrement
c'était plutôt celle qui était
quelconque et qui gagné pas mal d'argent
et qu'ils me paient leur loyer
je pensais que les hommes nés est ce que
les filles très belle mais c'est pas
vrai parce qu'une fille très belle c'est
comme un homme très beau et laid la ra
regardez moi je suis très belle j'ai pas
besoin de me fatiguer j'ai toujours
trouvé que les filets plus quelconques
était celle qui rapportait le plus au
lit ce sont des modèles ce sont elles
qui gagnent le plus d'argent alors que
les filles très belle j'ai souvent eu
pas mal d'ennuis avec petit à petit j'ai
compris que les hommes ne recherchait
pas les filles très belle l'une des
choses qu'on demande à une fille et en
tant qu'homme vous serez d'accord avec
moi celle enthousiasme
c'est ça le plus important qu'elle se
montre enthousiaste j'ai mis vingt ans à
comprendre ça c'est ici dans cette
maison doit organiser les partouzes des
poussières d'angleterre c'est un peu
loin de londres
cette petite somme qui arrivèrent d'une
simple dix nageurs la reine mère commune
à vélo qui ouvre un bordel d'affaires de
hors la loi parce qu'on a toujours
tendance à croire que le bordel c'est en
plein centre de l'ombre à sow mais en
fait comme c'était un endroit très
retirer ça me plaisait beaucoup
personne là bas ne savais que je tenais
un bordel j'avais pour voisins le
célèbre musicien carl davis il habitait
juste à côté et sa femme n'était pas au
courant
une personne à la fois vous aviez ici
pop art tous organisait une partie il y
avait 25 ou 35 hommes et 15 ou s'essuie
autant que je pouvais en trouver
partout dans toutes les pièces salle de
bains lâchant un coup c'est la cuisine
le jour il ya eu la descente de police
pas celle de 86,1 celle de 80 c'était
noël il y avait 50 hommes 50 hommes est
à peu près 25 filles jamais encore je
n'avais reçu 50 hommes à la fois jamais
mais c'était noël et j'avais plein
d'amis et c'est ce jour là que la police
a choisi pour faire une récente il y
avait 50 ans alors bien sûr ça fait très
mauvais effet quand j'étais au tribunal
j'ai dû expliquer que d'habitude il y
avait 25 ou 30 hommes mais là il y en
avait cinq ans elle en a tous été
emmenés au poste de police
si l'on prend les photos des coupes sur
les lits ils ont défoncé les portes
comme vous avez vu ont défoncé la porte
de ma chambre pour prendre le genre de
fille vous aviez quel genre de fille
tous les gens des filles qui
travaillaient dans des fermes des
institutrices quelques prostituées
certaines étaient prostituées d'autres
l'était pas oui c'était une atmosphère
vraiment très amicale très chaleureuse
et après pas mal d'années j'ai même
réussi à faire venir mon père ça veut
faire une prostituée à votre fils pour
son anniversaire et après vous avez
offert la même fille à votre père non
c'était pas la même fille ça c'est pas
vrai c'est la seule chose dans le film
corner paix mais je trouve qu'ils
auraient dû mettre d'office différents
mon père était quelqu'un de très
strictes
victorien il n'aurait jamais fait
l'amour devant scientifique ça comme mon
père venait qu'il apprenait que mon fils
était là il ne montait pas il est venu
mais jamais quand son petit fils était
là c'est la seule chose qui ne soit pas
véridique dans le film l'histoire
défiant kaduna c'est arrivé mais ce
n'était pas la même
c'était quel genre de père version ici
cette version je trouve que c'est un
très vilain mans moi je préfère parler
de ceux qui s'écartent de l'année parce
que les personnes qu'on appelle des
pervers se sentent tout à fait normal
jean l'état l'inversé je trouve que le
mot ne devrait pas exister
ça veut juste dire quelque chose d'un
peu différent d'un rapport sexuel
normale une fois on avait un directeur
de banque qui voulait qu'on la tâche
bras et jambes écartées après contre le
mur et il voulait de l'âme
il voulait qu'on le couvre de boue j'ai
des photos jaunies entre rennes il a
bien voulu se laisser photographier
parce qu'on ne peut pas le reconnaître
moi je voulais pas le faire je disais
que ça ferait trop de saleté parce qu'en
plus ils voulaient pas payer très cher
mais j'avais un ami qui adorait ce genre
de truc qui m'a dit allez on va le faire
on va organiser tout une fête
alors j'ai dit d'accord mais c'est toi
qui nettoiera après ça la guide d'accord
on n'arrivait pas à trouver de la boum
parce que c'était l'été et que la terre
était dû alors vous savez les dès que
j'ai eu
j'ai pensé à prendre tourner la
poussière qui avait dans mon sac
d'aspirateur j'ai été chercher mon
aspirateur j'évite les toute la
poussière on a attaché à on la
badigeonner avec de l'huile
on lui a versé toute la poussière dessus
et on a organisé une partie il y avait
un médecin dès vos quartiers quelques
policiers qui regarde et il y avait
seulement une fille ça a duré plusieurs
heures en fait c'était très ennuyeux
mais c'est ce qu'il voulait il voulait
que tout son corps soit souillée il
voulait être couverts de boue et il
voulait que le miroir que vous voyez là
bas soit devant lui pour qu'il puisse
voir la différence entre vous et madame
claude il ya beaucoup de différences
bien sûr j'ai tenu un bordel pour
l'argent mais j'en ai retiré beaucoup de
plaisir je crois que madame claude est
davantage une femme d'affaires mes
clients pour la plupart c'était des
hommes assez âgées qui avaient perdu
leurs femmes et il y avait aussi des
handicapés et je crois que pour la
majorité des madame ce qui compte c'est
que les clients aient de l'argent - plus
les clients étaient eux plus j'étais
gentil envers eux mêmes s'ils n'avaient
pas d'argent je les laisser entrer
gratuitement et il pouvait regarder
[Musique]
vous savez certains hommes à 80 ans ils
ne peuvent plus mais il adore regarder
alors quand un client n'avait pas
d'argent si je l'aimé bien cela en
faisait pitié
le fait qu'il n'ait pas d'argent ça ne
changeait rien il ya beaucoup de gens
que j'ai laissé entrer gratuitement
ça a été prouvé au tribunal lors de mes
deux jugements ou été debesque est la
meilleure manière de faire bander un mec
cas dans les 80 ans à peu près tout
quels conseils donneriez vous à une
fille nue épouse il faut que le malaise
un vieil homme mois face à une jeune
fille se sont parfois gêné parce qu'un
vieil homme n'aime pas déshabiller pour
une jeune fille c'est mon père qui m'a
expliqué sa mon père m'a dit j'aimerais
bien une fille et je vais trouver une
fille d'environ 28 ans lui avait 68 ans
et il m'a dit non c'est une tragédie
pourquoi il m'a dit je serais trop gêné
si j'étais plus jeune je te dirai
d'accord mais j'ai dit
ventre je serais gêné de me déshabiller
pour une jeune femme il faudrait que tu
me trouves une femme d'environ 35
ça laisse donc il faut vraiment mettre
l'homme à l'air ces cas ça moi je trouve
que le meilleur moyen pour faire bander
un homme surtout quand il a bu un verre
de trop
c'est libre ma soeur généralement je
garde à vivre ma soeur sous la ligne et
quand un client avait trop bu et la
fille ne rêvez pas le faire jouer je
branchais le vibromasseur utilisés qu'en
dernier recours lorsque la machine c'est
vraiment le dernier pour un homme de 80
ans c'est fini les pulsions sexuelles
chez l'homme c'est time vers 67 68 69
ans après son bond plus quoi pas
facilement mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'ils n'éprouvent pas du plaisir à
regarder les autres mais il y en avait
une autre celle ci elle était très bien
fait très joli mais les clients se
plaignaient car à chaque fois qu'elle
faisait l'amour elle gardait une
cigarette allumée en train de se
consumer dans le cendrier comme vous
faites et des fois elle faisait une pie
pour clients et les clients me disait
parce que les clients quand ils
n'étaient pas contents ils venaient se
plaindre il me disait et les jolies mais
elle est vraiment un peu trop
décontractés alors demandé pourquoi il
me répondait et bien elle est en train
de me faire une pipe et puis tout d'un
coup elle s'arrête elle dit excusez moi
il faut que je prenne une bouffée et
elle prenait la cigarette dans le
cendrier et elle faisait ça plusieurs
fois et à la fin
g elle avait sa cigarette qui se
consumer pendant la pub quoi elle était
très jolie mais elle était un peu trop à
l'aise n'était pas assez pro quoi il y
avait une autre fille qui était vraiment
très très jolie elle se faisait appeler
la princesse indienne
alors elle elle parlait politique quand
elle était au lit avec un client
elle finissait par se disputer avec lui
et il fallait que je rembourse le client
parce qu'elle était très jolie mais elle
était vraiment trop préoccupés par la
politique et je ne sais pas si elle
parlait politique pendant ou après mais
j'ai dû leur envoyer toutes les filles
qui étaient très belle j'ai dû les
renvoyer il y avait toujours quelque
chose qui n'allait pas avec elle ce que
je faisais c'est que quand un client
n'était pas satisfait je le remboursait
j'ai vu beaucoup d'handicapés sur vos
photos vous receviez ici tessa worley
psd handicapé je faisais l'amour avec un
handicap et surtout les hommes en
fauteuil roulant lorsque l'occasion de
sortir de chez amène à tct revenir à mes
soirées un client qui venait avec son
fils qui avait 25 ans c'était une
famille juive
il avait beaucoup d'argent il ne
confiait jamais son fils à personne et
il a mené son fils ici dans son fauteuil
roulant
on le mettait ici ils sont personnes
allaient et je disais au père mais
pourquoi vous ne restez pas pourquoi
vous ne vous gênez pas mais il répondait
non ce serait gênant pour david je vous
le confirme
des fois le fils passé la nuit ici et
son père venait le chercher le lendemain
matin c'était la seule occasion pour
l'autre sortir
mettait son fauteuil ici son fauteuil
roulant et il regarde et des fois on se
débrouillait pour lui trouver une fille
mais fait quand les filles voulaient pas
parce qu'il avait la partie inférieure
du corps tout atrophiée à partir de là
talent autrement il était très beau
j'avais un peu du mal à trouver des
filles qui fasse l'amour avec lui enfin
j'en trouvais quand même et il était
content et on le poussait dans son
fauteuil roulant jusqu'à une chambre sur
le palier bien sûr parce qu'on pouvait
pas lui faire monter l'escalier ont
gardé cette chambre au rez-de-chaussée
pour les handicapés temps en temps il
avait de la chance mais
quand il n'avait pas de chance quand ils
n'avaient pas de filles qui voulaient
aller avec lui il était content quand
même de se trouver avec des gens normaux
et il voulait être avec des journalistes
il ne voulait pas se retrouver seulement
avec des antilles je me suis toujours
demandé pourquoi on faisait ça ou
handicapées pourquoi on les isoler c'est
triste
la dernière fois que la police a fait
une descente chez moi il avait des
handicaps tient ici et ils ont dû les
faire sortir dans leur fauteuil roulant
les policiers les ont emmenés et les ont
mis dans des voitures spéciales et toute
la presse et tous les photographes
étaient là pour voir tout ça était
imprimé dans les jouets donc je ne sais
pas qui avait averti la presse
elle est à voir une des sentiments mais
en tout cas elle a été prévenue et des
fois vous trouviez des filles qui
voulaient faire l'amour avec les
handicapés oui ça toutes les filles ne
voulaient pas je devais leur demander
avant est ce que ça vous gêne je crois
qu'il n'y a eu que deux fois j'ai eu du
mal à lui trouver parce que beaucoup de
ces handicapés était malade sa c'est le
cadeau d'anniversaire de monfils pour
ses 16 ans elle est jolie non vous avez
un fils et si vous aviez une fille vous
aimeriez qu'elle participe à des
partages avait eu une fille j'aurais été
très très stricte avec elle mais
heureusement j'ai eu un fils et ça me
plaisait de lui choisir des filles parce
que je savais quel genre de fille les
mails des filles avec les chats je
prenais beaucoup de plaisir et s'il lui
trouver le genre de fille qu'il aimait
donc à partir de l'âge de 17 ans
maintenant il en alla 30/4
il a toujours eu les meilleures filles
maintenant il est marié j'ai des petits
enfants
mais si j'avais eu une fille je ne sais
pas ce que j'aurais fait je crois que
j'en aurai pas permis de participer à ça
avec un garçon c'est différent je
n'aurais pas permis à ma fille
d'entraînement que j'attendais des
enfants j'espérais toujours que ce sera
des gares soir parce que je savais ce
que c'était
j'étais content d'avoir des garçons si
vous deviez recommencer votre vie vous
feriez la même chose oui je voudrais
être membre du parlement en 1981 je
voudrais essayer de faire changer les
lois sur les moeurs en angleterre parce
que l on de 150 ans ça serait quoi votre
programme
mon programme est bien je serai
indépendante parce que je n'ai jamais eu
pour habitude de suivre la ligne d'un
parti quel qu'il soit je compte donc
être indépendante et je crois que
beaucoup de gens en angleterre tous ces
attentats sexuels commis sur des enfants
en angleterre
j'attribue ça au fait qu'il n'ya pas de
bordel en angleterre et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu